breaking bad killed countless characters
during its five-season run from lowly
dealers to innocent bystanders to a
certain karaoke loving scientist but
which one was the most devastating of
all keep watching and decide for
yourself
domingo crazy 8 melina and his cousin
emilio just wanted to sell a little meth
with emilio's friend jesse pinkman in
the normal world that might not be the
most sympathetic goal but in the world
of breaking bad that's as close to an
honest living as it often gets but when
a meeting with jesse and walter white go
sideways in the series first episode
emilio ends up dead and crazy eight is
held prisoner in jesse's basement
walt and jesse's dilemma is clear crazy
eight is an extreme liability and needs
to be dealt with in a more permanent
fashion than simply being chained up but
at this point neither men are killers
walt's misgivings only grow as he and
domingo make a personal connection
domingo's family owns the furniture
store where walt bought the crib for his
now teenage son
16 years ago how old would you have been
it was after school trust me i was there
it isn't until walt realizes that crazy
eight has armed himself with a shard of
broken dinner plate that his survival
instincts kick in the ensuing fight and
death scene is brutal and ugly tragedy
not just for the young man but for walt
himself as he has now crossed the line
from which he can never return
the deaths of emilio and crazy eights
are in many ways the show's original sin
and the consequences reverberates all
the way to the final episode and beyond
actions on breaking bad often have
unintended and disastrous consequences
season two is perhaps the most explicit
example of this culminating in a series
of small and large-scale tragedies that
occur as a result of walt and jesse's
fledgling meth operation after their
disastrous encounter with the mexican
drug cartel lieutenant tuko salamanca
the two attempt to produce and
distribute on their own walt takes the
street name heisenberg and jesse
recruits his goofball stoner friends
badger skinny pete and combo to handle
sales of the three jessie is closest
with combo in a season 3 flashback scene
we even learned that the winnebago rb
that he and walt used to cook math
belong to combo's mother one morning
combo is working a street corner when a
black muscle car parks nearby with two
men inside watching him soon after a
young boy bicycles around the car honks
twice and before he knows what's
happened combo has been shot dead
combo's death directly leads walt to
seek out somewhat handle distribution of
his math which puts him in the sights of
the show's greatest antagonist chilean
chicken man gus fring jesse meanwhile
devastated by combo's death and hurt by
walt's all-business attitude slips
further into his addiction to heroin
artist and recovering drug addict jane
margulis is trying to piece her life
back together when she runs the other
side of her duplex to jesse in season
two as these things often go a somewhat
prickly business relationship warms into
a friendship and then to something more
but it's already a sad truth of the show
that no one can know walter jesse and
get away unscathed before long jesse and
jane's addictive personalities bring out
the worst in each other they also make
pie in the sky plans to get clean and
move to new zealand but first just one
more night of getting high waltz returns
later that night to make amends with
jessie and finds the two of them strung
out jane sleeping on her back begins to
throw up walt could roll her over but he
doesn't instead he watches jane choke to
death walt let jane die because he knew
her being with jesse would lead to his
eventual overdose one day and also
because she tried blackmailing him
threatening to expose his
drug-affiliated secrets jane was jesse's
last tether to a life outside of walt
the cartels and meth and his guilt
lingers for the remainder of the series
walt meanwhile feels little to no guilt
over jane's death and doesn't reveal his
role in her death to jessie until the
end of the series
i was there
and i watched her die but jesse was not
the only person to love jane and her
death has further consequences on a
massive scale the first episode of
season two teases a terrible future
event by depicting a mangled pink teddy
bear floating in the white family pool
the explanation when finally revealed in
the season two finale is unexpected yet
at the same time unavoidable a tragic
accident set in motion by every decision
walt and jessie ever made jane's death
hits jessie hard but it also devastates
her father donald an air traffic
controller who takes a few weeks off
from work in order to recover from his
grief when he finally returns to his
position at the albuquerque airport he
is shaky but ready to get back to his
routine at his council he guides
wayfarer flight 515 but his mind begins
to wander clear direct to albuquerque
via the
aircraft calling please stand by
suddenly wayfarer 515 collides with
another aircraft high above avq sending
bodies and debris flying all over the
city including straight into walt's
backyard a blunt but powerful metaphor
for the destruction he's brought upon
his family
months after jane's death jesse has
kicked his heroin habit and found a new
partner in young mom andrea contio
andrea looks after her young son brock
as well as her younger brother tomas who
is mixed up in gang activity but
albuquerque is a small town and jesse
soon makes a terrible discovery tomas is
the young boy who shot combo to death in
the street and the gang he is running
with is affiliated with gus fring jesse
goes to walt for help wanting to kill
the dealers using tomas but walt goes to
gus instead who calls a meeting and
declares that the gang is to no longer
use children in their business the
dealers agree and take gus's directions
literally by killing tomas now bent on
revenge for both andrea's brother and
combo jesse sets out to gun down the two
dealers and probably get himself killed
in the process as he's about to confront
them however walt plows his car into the
two kills one with a bullet to the head
and tells jesse
run
poor old gail bettiker gail is a gifted
chemist an all-around sweet guy a
karaoke fan and a man with the
incredible misfortune to be caught
between two of the coldest most paranoid
men alive walter white and gus fring
brought on as walt's assistant in the
french-built super lab in season three
gail and walt have a fruitful
partnership at first but walt grows
concerned that gail may be there as his
replacement rather than his assistant
and fabricates reasons to fire gail and
replace him with jesse after the deaths
of tomas and frank's two dealers jesse
goes into hiding what makes the deal to
forget about jesse and continue cooking
for gus with gail reluctantly returning
as his assistant this time walt's
paranoia is founded gus has indeed
brought gail back in order to take over
the super lab once walt and jesse have
been killed springs fixers mike and
victor take walt to the super lab to
kill him but not before walt calls jesse
who shows up at gayle's apartment with a
gun and shoots him at point blank range
the fifth episode of season five opens
on a young boy out in the desert alone
not much happens before the opening
credits roll and the boy isn't seen
again for nearly another hour after the
fiery death of gus spring at the end of
season four walt jesse and mike are now
their own bosses in the meth game with
all the responsibility that entails for
one they're dealing with gus's former
business partner at a german
conglomerate they have also hired a
young new assistant todd who is eager to
impress most importantly though they
need an industrial amount of methylamine
to continue production and the only way
to get it is to rob a freight train what
follows is a marvelously suspenseful
heist sequence as walt jesse and todd
conspired to bring the train to a halt
in the middle of the desert drain the
methylamine it's carrying replace it
with water and get out without getting
killed or caught it goes off of that
hitch and the three men are high off the
exhilaration that is until drew sharp
that young boy from the opening sequence
shows up again having witnessed
everything so without a second thought
todd pulls out a pistol and shoots him
dead
fan favorite character mike erman trout
was introduced at the end of season 2
with saul goodman's cleaner arriving at
jesse's apartment to take care of jane's
body and make sure nothing incriminating
is left in the house mike was soon
brought back as a recurring character in
seasons three and four an enforcer an
all-around bagman for gus spring by
season five he was business partners
with walt even in the company of
geniuses like gus and walt mike tends to
be the smartest guy in the room the
philly x-cop who's seen-it-all attitude
hides a deep moral code that moral code
is consistently offended however by
walter white many of the show's deaths
continue to weigh on him and mike
expresses an almost fatherly concern
toward jesse as he falls ever further
into walt's influence the money is good
so mike keeps working with him but
something's got to give that's something
finally does give when the dea catches
mike's lawyer distributing money to his
associates in prison paying for their
continued silence mike decides to skip
town but needs his emergency getaway bag
picked up from the airport walt delivers
it to him at some far away spot near a
creek and in their final conversation
mike lashes out blaming walt for ruining
the good deal they all had under gus
spring you just had to blow it up you
and your pride and your ego you just had
to be the man in a rage walt shoots mike
in the gut and this iconic character is
left to bleed out by the creek alpha
male dea agent hank schroeder loves his
family including his brother-in-law
walter white even if he and white don't
always understand each other introduced
in season one as a meathead jock gone to
seed hank bloomed over the course of the
series revealing hidden depths and
turning into someone the audience could
really root for by the season five's
mid-season finale in 2012 hank has
finally discovered that the drug
kingping heisenberg who he's been
hunting for nearly two years is in fact
his brother-in-law the rest of the
season concerns his fight to bring walt
to justice that struggle reaches a
terrible conclusion in the standout
episode ozymandias in the previous
episode hank and jesse team up and lure
walt out to the remote spot on a native
reservation where he has buried barrels
of cash hank slaps handcuffs on walt but
his triumph is short-lived as walt's new
business partners a gang of neo-nazis
led by todd's uncle jack show up as well
a shootout ensues that leaves hank
wounded walt tries to talk jack out of
killing hank but hank shuts him down
you're too stupid to see
he made up his mind 10 minutes ago jack
shoots him and walt's world finally
crumbles
of all of walter white's victims jesse
is arguably the one who suffers the most
he is put through the ringer in every
season and every time he tries to get
out walt's gravitational pull brings him
right back around for more punishment
the end of season 5 has jessie suffered
to an almost absurd degree as he is
kidnapped by todd and uncle jack after
hank's death and forced to cook math
walt meanwhile has fled to new hampshire
as the full ugly truth of his drug
empire comes to light if there's a
glimmer of hope in jessie's life though
it's the thought of seeing andrea and
brock again
todd knows this and in the series
penultimate episode he snuffs out half
of his hope after jesse tries to escape
and refuses to cook math he puts jesse
in the back of his truck and drives to
andrea's house todd knocks on the door
introduces himself to her as a friend of
jesse's and promptly shoots her in the
back of the head jesse screams in pain
and rage flailing trying to escape his
holds uncle jack sitting in the front
seat issues a chilling command
hey
remember you're still a kid
breaking bad really doesn't get much
more brutal than this check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]